welcome back to deepmind the podcast
with me hannah fry
for this series i've been speaking to
researchers at the cutting edge of ai to
find out what they're working on and the
implications it could have for all of us
in the last four episodes we've been
looking ahead to the long-term future of
ai including some of the ideas that
researchers hope will bring them to
artificial general intelligence
but in the next two episodes we want to
share with you some of the ways that ai
is already being put to work along the
way
here's deepmind ceo demus asabis
my personal reason for working on ai was
to use ai as the ultimate tool to
accelerate scientific discovery in
almost any field and i think alpha fold
is our first massive example of that
if you heard episode 1 you'll know all
about alpha fold deepmind's
state-of-the-art system that can
accurately predict the three-dimensional
structures of proteins
but alpha fold isn't the only science
project within these walls
step inside the labs and you'll find
researchers scrutinizing dna to
understand the mysteries of life
hunting for new ways to harness nuclear
energy or putting ai to the test in some
of the most mind-expanding areas of
mathematics
so what are you waiting for
come on in
this is episode six
ai for science
[Music]
push meet coley who we heard from in
episode one oversees deepmind's ai for
science program across the natural
sciences and when it comes to a list of
areas that are being worked on
he is exactly the man to ask biology
proteomics and genomics in
quantum chemistry like material design
fusion fundamental mathematics ecology
weather now that is a fairly
intimidating list but over the course of
the next 30 minutes or so i'll be
walking you through as many of them as
we can get to to give you a sense of the
potential for ai to make a difference to
science
first though you might be wondering why
a company that made its name getting ai
to play computer games became involved
in these serious scientific subjects and
that is where i started the conversation
with push meat
science has been in the dna of deep mind
from the very start it's more of the
case that as we sort of built up these
systems and
proved them on games we then started
thinking about now is a good time to
actually stress test them on the real
scientific challenges that society is
facing
for sarah jane dunn a research scientist
on the science team deepmind science
program is fundamental to the company's
aim of solving intelligence to advance
science and benefit humanity
that's quite an abstract concept to some
people
the point is you have
techniques that can tackle some of the
hardest problems that have eluded the
brightest minds for decades
and so i think being able to show
people the power of these technologies
to really help humanity
that for me is one of the most valuable
aspects of what we're doing in science
what the ai for science team does is try
to identify suitable scientific problems
for ai to work on that will go on to
have the biggest impact
one way of thinking about it is this
idea of the tree of knowledge there are
some problems which are the so-called
root node problems which unlock so many
other problems downstream protein
folding was one such example once you
understand the structure of proteins
that has implications for
developing new drugs or coming up with
new enzymes for breaking down plastics
another example would be
if you had a great source of energy
other problems like access to clean
water become much more tractable once
you have unlimited energy at your
disposal and then once we have sort of
isolated some of these root note
problems we then think about
what is the role machine learning and ai
has to play
and now that deep mind has made
significant progress on protein folding
it's turning to some of those other root
node problems that push me mentioned
one of them is nuclear fusion
[Music]
it's hard to emphasize just how big an
impact a breakthrough in nuclear fusion
might have
it is the long-held dream of scientists
around the world that one day we would
be able to fuse two hydrogen atoms
together and in doing so create a
totally unlimited totally clean and safe
supply of energy
it would spell the end of our climate
crisis
but before we get too carried away i
should tell you that nuclear fusion is
really hard
to get atoms to fuse you first have to
heat them up until they form something
called a plasma a state of matter that
is so hot that the electrons are
stripped from the atoms
here's demises to explain one of the
really hard things about fusion is how
do you contain this plasma that's like
as hot as the sun and
it would burn anything obviously they're
touched so the way you have to contain
it is in a magnetic field the problem is
that the plasma is almost in a chaotic
regime so at any moment a bit of it
might just sort of shoot down a certain
direction and you have to change the
magnetic field quick enough to respond
to that to keep hold of the plasma for
multiple seconds
the plasma is held inside something
called a tokamak
it's like a giant metal donut big enough
to walk through
the magnets around the edge create a
field strong enough to suspend the
plasma in the middle away from the sides
but the plasma is wobbly and unstable
and as soon as it touches anything it's
game over
the comparatively cold sides of the
tokamak saps the energy from the plasma
and the heat dissipates almost instantly
up till now what people have done in the
physics world is they've hand written
mathematical controllers for what the
plasma might do whereas our system what
it's learned to do is predict what the
plasma might do
from the shape of it and then almost
ahead of time change the magnetic field
to react to what it thinks is going to
happen and even more excitingly we're
actually doing like plasma sculpting so
we can actually split it into two or
elongate it it's almost like ice
sculpture but with plasma that's as hot
as the sun yeah it's a hot as a sun
but as push meat explains it's not just
about keeping the plasma stable it's
also about which configuration of the
plasma you are keeping stable there are
certain configurations which produce
more heat and what reinforcement
learning now allows you to do is
basically
you can say i want this funky
configuration because i think that it is
going to be more stable or it will
produce more heat capacity and so on and
the ai is like yeah i can do it for you
rather than sort of a human spending a
year of their time sort of thinking
about how to control the different
current in the coils and how to maintain
the right voltages and so on for that
particular configuration i see so it's a
shortcut basically it accelerates the
whole research cycle amazing
and as if protein folding and nuclear
fusion weren't enough to keep the ai for
science team busy they've been pursuing
a raft of other projects including in
the field of ecology
this has taken ai out of the science lab
and into a setting where you might not
expect to find it at work
where we're working in the serengeti is
very classic
lion king east african landscape so you
have the rolling grasslands it started
with those iconic acacia trees broad
open savannas
meredith palmer is a conservation
biologist at princeton university in new
jersey but you'll usually find her with
a pair of binoculars out in the field
you have something like 700 species of
birds 50 species of large mammals
that are traversing around the greater
serengeti ecosystem
so down from tanzania up into kenya in
this kind of endless circle chasing the
rains
and when the migration comes back into
town you can hear the bleeding of the
wildebeest the sounds of the flies that
are following the migration around
this annual gathering of animals the
great migration as it's known
is one of the last in the world and one
of many reasons that ecologists are so
interested in the serengeti we have
lions but we also have cheetah and wild
dog and hyena and leopard
and all of these species are trying to
co-exist
and so to understand all of the
interconnections between these wildlife
we need to be studying these wildlife
communities
unfortunately though climate and
agricultural change as well as illegal
poaching are all having a growing impact
on the local ecosystem
about a decade ago to help them monitor
changes in the serengeti ecologists
installed devices known as camera traps
across a 1 200 square kilometer area of
serengeti national park
camera traps are
small remote cameras we can strap them
to a tree
and leave them running 24 hours a day
seven days a week for months or even
years
the camera traps are triggered by the
heat and motion of passing animals to
take pictures we can examine the images
to see what animals are in them and what
these animals are doing
as you might expect these camera traps
take a lot of pictures lots of fantastic
candid shots and lots that show the back
of an animal or some shape that's a bit
hard to discern
imagine letting a four-year-old run
loose with your phone and then scrolling
through the camera roll at the end it's
a bit like that
these camera traps are producing
10 to 20 000 images a month so we as
ecologists are really facing this
massive
deluge of data and the big issue for us
is that we can't use the images straight
out of the camera trap to address our
research and conservation questions
someone has to go and look at each and
every one of these tens of hundreds of
thousands of images
and write down you know this image
contains
three adult zebra and one baby zebra i
once calculated that it would take me
seven or eight years to process a single
year's worth of image data
faced with all this data meredith and
her colleagues became early adopters of
citizen science we essentially
crowdsourced the classification process
and you could look at our camera trap
pictures and identify all of the animals
and behaviors that you saw in our field
data
after a while though a problem arose as
the number of citizen science projects
exploded the snapshot serengeti project
as it was called could no longer attract
enough volunteers to manually go through
all of the images that needed labeling
snapshot serengeti's impressive data set
of labeled wildlife images caught the
attention of researchers at deepmind
they got in touch offering to train a
computer vision algorithm that would
automatically classify the thousands of
photos taken by the camera traps
identifying which particular species of
gazelle for example appears in a photo
it blows my mind how incredible
ai can be for solving these kinds of
problems
i've had moments where
i've looked at an image and had a
computer identify a species i you know
on first glance didn't even recognize
was there
so there's some animals that the ai is
99 on all of the time
however
if we don't have a lot of labeled images
the algorithm doesn't do so well
so there's a lot of these cryptic rare
little species aardvarks cirillas
servals janet's and when we only have a
couple hundred images of those
the computer can get a little wonky just
because it doesn't know what to look for
computer vision systems and pretty much
all ai systems come to that are only as
good as the data they're trained on
which also explains why the ai sometimes
struggles with those creatures at the
top of the animal kingdom
one issue that we discovered using human
volunteers to classify our data
is that people really really really want
to see lions
we've had images where
it's a warthog sunning itself and our
citizen scientists have very confidently
classified that image as containing one
very impressive male lion
and no i'm sorry it's not it's a warthog
we do have a lot of checks and balances
for making sure that we're feeding
the ai the very best labeled image data
that we can but some of these things
slip through the cracks
the community of serengeti ecologists
are already starting to see the benefits
in their monitoring efforts
tanzania used to have an enormous
population of black rhinoceros but that
has dwindled to fewer than a hundred
2019 nine black rhinoceros were
reintroduced into the grameti game
reserve a part of the serengeti
ecosystem that is monitored by camera
traps in conjunction with ai technology
we'll be able to look at if migration
routes change we'll also be able to
document any impacts of new mega
herbivore effects on the surrounding
human communities
we've documented several of the
rhinoceros consorting with each other
so we anticipate that we're probably
going to have a couple of baby
rhinoceros to look forward to
in the next year or two
for meredith the future is not for ai to
replace ecologists but to complement
them
the way we've been doing ecology to date
you know out there in the field with our
binoculars and our notepads watching
you know a single warthog all day like
it's not fast enough and the more that
we can get a helping hand from ai
the faster we can identify the problems
that are driving change in the ecosystem
the more targeted conservation
interventions that we can make
to save and protect and rebuild these
ecosystems
[Music]
we've heard how computer vision systems
are being used to make sense of biology
and wildlife on a vast scale
but as we heard with alpha fold deepmind
is also using ai to understand life at a
microscopic scale
back in the science lab researchers have
been trying their hand at genomics an
area of biology dedicated to
understanding human genes and dna
deep minds genomics work is still in its
very early stages
so what are push meet coley's hopes for
the future of this research
the implications could be very
wide-ranging if you truly understand
biology then you understand how
all cells behave even cancer cells so
you might have better treatment for
cancer you might have better ways of
creating new
organs for transplantation what you're
describing here really there is a
potential step change in all of
healthcare and medicine that is the
implication of truly understanding
biology we have in some sense been
observing biology
but to truly leverage biology that's
something that humanity
is only starting to understand the
implications of
so
are you ready to get up to speed on a
brand new bit of science
i'm game if you are
i started out life as a mathematician
but when i was thinking about what to do
i was wasn't so taken with the idea
maybe of studying fluid flow down a pipe
for three years no offense to to me
which is exactly what i did
sorry
this is the delightful sarah jane dunn a
research scientist working on the
genomics project
genomics it's a domain of biology and
it's most interested in understanding
the connection between your genotype
that's basically your dna sequence and
phenotype and that's everything from how
tall you are to what color hair you have
to maybe whether you have some
particular disease or not
genotype is what you see in the dna
phenotype
is what you get
i have the mc1r genotype rs185005
which gives me the phenotype of red hair
genotype cftr delta f508
gives the phenotype of cystic fibrosis
those however are the examples where the
connection between genotype and
phenotype is clear and established
unfortunately such examples are the
exception rather than the rule
take for example the bracha one gene
which is linked to the development of
breast cancer
not all people with the braca one
mutation will go on to develop breast
cancer but there's currently no way of
knowing which people with the gene are
more at risk
in some cases this has led some women
with the bracha one gene to have surgery
as a precaution the hope is that a
deeper understanding of genomics may
provide important additional context
about what puts someone at increased
risk or not
if we could unpack more about how the
rest of your dna sequence can tell us
about the progression of that disease
then we might be able to make more
nuanced diagnoses about these kind of
things and then projecting into the
future
how might you be able to change that
before the disease actually develops how
might you be able to to develop the most
effective quick treatments those are all
questions that are open to us after that
[Music]
research in genomics builds upon an
important foundation known as the human
genome project
starting in 1990 the project took the
full set of dna of one anonymous human
their genome and over the course of a
decade went through every molecule one
by one
every single one of the three billion
chemical base pairs a t
c and g
that combine together to give some
twenty 000 or so genes
and a whole lot more besides
thus providing the entire manual for how
to make a human
but in some ways this was just the
starting point
the human genome project
successfully
was able to compile
this whole sort of cookbook for a human
you have bought this book and there's a
saying but you don't know how to read it
that's what scientists are sort of
struggling with
you can think of the amazing human
cookbook as a literal book by the way
one of the early versions of the human
genome project was printed and bound as
part of an art project and it's stacked
up as some 20 phone book size volumes
where every page inside was a blur of
a's t's c's and g's
and therein lies part of the problem
we still have very little idea about how
much of it comes together to form the
cells tissues and organs in the human
body
it is a list of ingredients
but it's not in order and that's what we
are trying to understand how do you
decipher
the actual
sort of cooking process
so you've got one end some flour eggs
milk and a cow yeah and at the other end
you've got a beef pie and you're like
what the hell happened in between
yeah exactly
in humans only about two percent of our
dna actually goes towards our genes the
remaining 98 of those 20 odd phone books
worth of biological instructions are
what they officially call the non-coding
region
less officially biologists have referred
to it as junk dna you know that shows
how much we were interested in it but
after the human genome project was
completed it became obvious that this
so-called junk dna was actually really
important
by now we know what some of the junk
does
some of it is structural stuff like the
scaffolding needed for when a cell is
working
some of it is just random nonsense
but a lot of it is on and off switches
a series of regulators that tell genes
when to get to work
what's interesting is that you know all
of the cells of your body share that
genome but they make use of it in
different ways and they do that by
expressing some genes and not others
every cell contains a complete copy of
every gene but will only require a
handful of genes to be active at any one
time
a gene that prompts cell division is no
use in a tissue which has finished
growing otherwise it could lead to a
tumor
a gene that is active in building hair
or teeth has no role in the cells that
make up the liver or the heart
the hope in all this is that if you can
understand the on and off switches as
well as everything we already know about
genes and proteins it can help
biologists to better understand the
mechanism by which certain diseases take
hold in the body
take for example sickle cell disease an
inherited health condition affecting red
blood cells
there are of course certain signs of
this disease in someone's phenotype if
you look at the red blood cells under a
microscope those that belong to someone
with a disease will take on a
characteristic shape like a crescent
moon
thanks to the human genome project we
now also know that there are certain
changes in the dna that are common among
people with sickle cell anemia
what's still unknown and where genomics
can help
is how
that sequence of letters in someone's
non-coding dna
translates into how the disease will
progress in individual cells
if you're wanting to then understand how
this disease
actually arises in the body and then
ultimately how you might treat it you
need to go through these layers of
information you need to understand well
what does that change the dna sequence
actually
do within the cell does it mean that the
cell can no longer express certain genes
does this give us targets for what we
might be able to attack in that cell to
develop kind of drug treatments so it's
about
understanding from that very first clue
about what might give someone a disease
how it kind of bubbles up from that
basic level of dna
that
is where ai and deep mind's work on
genomics fits in
there is some precedent here already
scientists have a whole series of
special cases where they've already
cracked the connection between dna
sequences and cell function these
studies all serve as a solid foundation
of biological data for deep minds 4a
into genomics research
we're trying to build ai that
essentially can understand the genome
the fact is we now have the kind of
level of data where deep learning can
really take hold and we've been able to
build together the kind of deep learning
models that are able to read a dna
sequence a bit like you might read a
piece of text
as a first step in its genomics work
deepmind is using a relatively new idea
in the world of machine learning a type
of architecture called a transformer
it's useful to think of it as a sort of
translator
it reads in a string of letters from dna
and based on the sequence of a's and t's
and c's and g's it will translate it
into a prediction for how the genes will
actually manifest themselves
to do language translation well you need
to pay most attention to the key words
in a sentence and the transformer uses
the same idea applied to dna
as it runs through the code it holds on
to the most important parts of the
sequence the bits that are most likely
to provide the relevant bits of context
and it pays less attention to all the
filler bits the dna equivalent of all of
the ands and the ins and the vers in a
sentence
you need more context to be able to make
better and better predictions because
some of the things that can influence
what's happening are positioned further
and further along the dna sequence and
so the transformer architecture that we
build is able to swallow in about 10
times as much of that dna sequence
that's 10 times more of the dna sequence
than previous ai models could read
by being able to extend how much context
the model had about the dna sequence we
were able to increase the accuracy of
our predictions about gene expression
from sequence
this all sounds pretty positive
but before we make it sound like machine
learning or ai is some sort of silver
bullet for all problems in biology and
science it's important to sound a note
of caution too
unfortunately there isn't a big button
labeled machine learning in the corner
where you can just gather any old data
hit the button and get out great science
to use ai effectively you have to ask
the right question that for me is one of
the biggest challenges to say okay i
know that there's a big question in the
field about how we can
you know differentiate a progenitor cell
into a heart cell because we'd like to
be able to make them in the lab so that
we can treat people with heart disease
but how can you take something like that
and then wield ai effectively it's being
able to understand
first of all what kind of question you
should be asking and then what kind of
architecture is going to be able to deal
with those data but then also how do you
know if your model's getting better or
worse so it very much is still an area
of research
the other thing about using ai the
sophisticated pattern hunter that it is
is that it doesn't always give you a
good answer for why those patterns
appear
do we have to be nervous about
making predictions without really
understanding the causal mechanisms yes
i think so but it doesn't mean that
these kind of tools aren't valuable the
thing i like about ai is that it can
allow us to
handle some of the complexity that
biology throws at us and
often when we're dealing with biological
data we're dealing with very noisy data
and data that has been perturbed by just
experimental error and so if we have the
tools that can somehow surf over some of
those
bumps in the data and try to really pull
out those meaningful patterns then the
thing that we have to be really rigorous
about is how we interpret it and it's
not the only tool that should be
deployed but if it gives us pointers in
the right direction if it steps us
forward that one piece then that is
still valuable
but it's all very well for computer
scientists to turn up in some new
scientific domain hoping to plant their
flag
as we've heard machine learning
techniques like alpha fold and this
genomics work build heavily on existing
scientific data that is often obtained
using painstaking experimental methods
so how do other scientists respond when
they hear that ai could be applied to
their domain
scientists are
a very competitive bunch but they are
very collaborative as well if they are
convinced
that the approach that you are proposing
is an approach worth pursuing
they are interested in listening to you
have you ever struggled to persuade
people though
so when we started looking at applying
machine learning and ai to pure
mathematics
we encountered a number of
mathematicians who were very very keen
and became really good collaborators but
there were a few who
on matters of principle
thought that mathematics is a very human
endeavor and a machine has no role to
play in it
i'm shocked personally
i'm shocked that some pure
mathematicians might not welcome the
future with open arms
you're probably wondering what that pure
mathematics project was all about
well the first thing that you need to
know is that in pure mathematics proof
reigns supreme
someone might have a conjecture like
there are an infinite number of prime
numbers for instance but that means
nothing until by a chain of logical
statements it can be proven to be
indisputably true for all eternity
so what we were interested in is can a
computer have that intuitive ability to
propose a new conjecture what we started
looking at with some of our sort of
collaborators is about
different aspects of not theory and
topology which was suspected to have
some interactions but nobody had sort of
discovered those relationships
not theory you will not be surprised to
hear is all about the mathematical study
of knots
i know the name might not make it sound
exciting but you're just gonna have to
take my word for it on this one that the
whole field is a glorious playground of
bending and twisting loops of imaginary
string
there are different ways to describe
these knots an algebraic way
and a geometric way and it's quite hard
to translate from one to the other
but then ai started hunting for
connections
and that resulted in a new conjecture
which had never been seen before and not
only that the human mathematicians then
managed to prove that conjecture
so in some sense it's basically humans
who are proving the conjectures that a
computer has come up with did that
persuade the grand pp or mathematicians
i don't think we went back to them
[Laughter]
and that is just a flavor of some of the
science applications that deepmind is
currently hard at work on
from ecology to genomics protein folding
to nuclear fusion the ways in which ai
could make a genuine difference to our
lives in the near future are
increasingly clear
and there are so many more projects that
we didn't have time to cover in this
episode
so if you'd like to find out more about
the ai for science program do take a
look at the show notes or check out
deepmind.com
in the next episode we'll continue to
discover how the applications of ai
could have an impact on the real world
from weather prediction to voice
synthesis
i'm a mathematician author and podcaster
who's fascinated by artificial
intelligence
it's really good i know it's good am i
that breathy bloody hell
you've been listening to deepmind the
podcast
i'm hannah fry and the series producer
is dan hardoon at whistledown
productions
we'll be back soon